okay so schnell funktioniert das ich
gehe jetzt wieder offline weil
ja ich bin gerade live gehen auf eure
Handys und guckt mal weil ich weiß ne
deswegen wie geht es also dann wie geht
es uns gleich ja bei wem bin ich jetzt
live das kann doch nicht sein
bei Youtube du bist bei Youtube
nein bei YouTube
bei Youtube meine ich doch
ich probiere es jetzt gerade aus ja ich
bin gerade live
aber leise machen sonst hört man das
hi zusammen ich probiere gerade aus ob
ich bei HI Anna herzlichen Glückwunsch
zum Geburtstag
alles Sophia ja ich habe mir gedacht ich
gehe heute mal ganz kurz live denn ich
bin morgen Abend live auf Youtube und
auf Instagram und habe noch nie
tatsächlich ein glaube ich ein
Livestream auf Youtube gemacht mit dem
Handy werden es bisher immer mit der
großen Kamera deswegen wollte ich das
kurz ausprobieren ey ich muss sagen auf
Youtube das funktioniert da kommen voll
viele gleich live du bist
ich bin in meiner ich bin bei Youtube
live hey ihr seid ja mal cool könnt ihr
mir mal schreiben habt ihr gerade eine
Benachrichtigung gekriegt dass ich jetzt
live gegangen bin oder warte jetzt
gerade zufällig sowieso in der Youtube
App und seit deswegen drauf gestoßen
also schreibt mir mal gerne wie ihr
jetzt zu diesem Live Event gefunden habt
das würde mich jetzt interessieren oh
danke für die lieben Grüße
das ist sehr cool atember
Benachrichtigung erhalten okay
auch sehr cool okay dann müssen wir es
morgen auch so machen wir gehen morgen
dann einfach live morgen Abend ist es
also alle die jetzt hier sind ihr wisst
schon mal Bescheid alle 500 ich erwarte
euch morgen Abend auch live und wenn ihr
eine Benachrichtigung bekommen habt
müssen wir so zwei drei Minuten so
bisschen einleiten und so weiter bis
alle da sind und dann ja ich mache so
lange aber Konzert und dann können wir
unseren coolen Abend machen
sehr schön sehr schön hallo Anna
schreibt einen ralforscher
also dann bis morgen ich gehe morgen
noch mal live und hier alle Mädels und
Jungs sind dann auch mit dabei tschüss